so he's a presbyterian minister and a us
army chaplain
the crucifixion that jesus peace be upon
him who we love is one of them be
confirmed as a member of the
presbyterian church to take my first
communion
for the first time i found myself making
salah as if i were a muslim
oh and and he looked at me kind of
incredulously you mean you're not
you're not muslim i said no sir well
what are you
well you know i had i had the rap down
you know i'm
probably more like i don't know maybe an
agnostic paga buddhist
and he said mashallah you're in the
perfect place
the deed the the show
[Music]
subscribe if you haven't already and
continue
to tune in here every week we have an
exciting guest
exciting episode we're not just telling
stories we're inspiring people
we're helping to change lives through
these stories now my next guest coming
on his father was a
christian minister he turned towards
being agnostic
and then he considered himself a pagan
buddhist
and the list goes on of things that he's
tried we're going to go ahead and bring
him on so he can
share his story and then how he ended up
here on the dean's show with my next
guest
don't go anywhere go ahead and subscribe
right now hit that notification bell
help us get our numbers back up did you
know that many years ago
the dean show when we started 2006 we
used to broadcast for many years on the
khalifa clothing channel
currently known as digital men but so
we're trying to get our numbers back up
because the channel
at that time got closed then we started
the official d show channel we're trying
to get our numbers back up to where they
should be
and that's this number here 855 combined
what we currently have 442
we should be over a million two hundred
000 subscribers help us to get our
numbers
back to where they should be with that
small setback that we had many years ago
you guys can help us by subscribing
right now and hitting that notification
bell
thank you very much enjoy the rest of
this show and don't forget to support us
on our patreon page assalamu alaikum
how you doing hugh eskol alaikum salaam
good to have good to be here thanks for
the invitation eddie
thank you for accepting that invitation
it it's quite new you accepted islam
maybe
what 2016. is that right
um yeah something like that okay
so yeah yeah so tell us now
you were let's start with the beginning
so i started off with your father being
a christian minister
he was uh let's go from there
so he's a presbyterian minister and a
u.s army chaplain
you know whether it was bringing the war
home with him
or uh he did two tours in vietnam
uh part of the u.s occupation of that
sovereign nation
um or you know maybe he just picked up
these bad habits as a kid but
you know he uh sexually abused and
physically abused me and my
siblings and you know when
the time came for me to uh
uh be confirmed as a member of the
presbyterian church to take my first
communion
you know just i didn't feel it didn't
didn't add up back then you know i
didn't understand
concepts like spiritual abuse and
you know all of that back then i just
knew that
the the stories they were telling us in
a
catechism class didn't really jive with
the
how he was in the world and um
so i wasn't feeling it apparently i
broke my grandmother's heart she cried
that day
but uh um yeah so
for probably 12 or 15 years i called
myself agnostic
uh after that but well let's back it up
from there someone
says look it's not about feeling the
truth or experience it the truth is the
truth it doesn't matter what kind of
yeah the person goes through and it's
really sad to hear these
experiences that people go through
because of human beings deficiencies
and the evil of human beings the evil
that human beings do
but now the truth is the truth so if
someone asks you well
hold on that was your experience other
people that i've experienced you know
why didn't you accept this as the truth
this way of life that your father was
upon in preaching
even though he was a bad example of it
and
you know that was that was my experience
of what being a part of the presbyterian
faith
you know was supposed to look like that
you abuse your children
you know and and i had you know
long before i uh was being asked to take
a first communion
you know it was clear that i was never
going to hit any child of mine
you know i i knew enough that that that
didn't
strike me as an appropriate way to be in
the world um
and you know i didn't i didn't have any
real examples of
you know what it was to to
be in a a faith community where people
were respectful of each other
or at least respectful of me i'm told
you know as with many abusive men that
he uh
you know he he put on a good show in
public
no one knew what happened in our home
that was back in the day when that was
all private and behind scenes and
didn't talk about it and it was even
legal in most states of this country
what was legal uh to abuse your children
in these ways
to abuse the woman you were married to
in these ways
you know and and so um
you know i i came by it was when you say
legal it wasn't a matter of
of public concern it wasn't a criminal
matter it was a private matter it was
you know men's violence has often been
shielded by
um you know what happens in the family
stays in the family and we don't have to
you know concern ourselves that's
someone else's private affair
what about what about the theology and
the teachings for instance
many people what gravitate them towards
islam is the pure monotheism
you know the simple message of being
morally upright
the quran all the evidence that it's
based on
so here with the theology of
christianity before we go into
agnosticism
what was it did it connect with you i
mean
how much did you know about the
teachings the trinity uh
jesus peace be upon him dying for your
sins the crucifixion what were your
thoughts on that
well um you know that
that trinity piece never really added up
for me honestly
and and so uh
coming to a community where people
weren't trying to pretend
that god was begating himself
you know cleared up some of that
confusion
um and you know i had been hearing the
stories and i continued to hear the
stories
uh church service was compulsory until
you know um until i was
pretty much in junior college uh
sunday school was compulsory almost as
long
and so i was exposed to the stories
ongoingly but
you know it just didn't
it was something i had to do on sunday
in order to
avoid a whipping it wasn't something
that i
you know that's not really a i was
really
taken by uh i
is it in uh al-baqarah i believe you
know that there's no compulsion in
matters of faith
are you talking about in the quran the
ayah the quran
i don't remember exactly where i i got
this sentence in in the second
uh surah but um you know the idea that
you know and politically i've long
counted myself as something of an
anarchist and so the idea that i'd be
coming into a faith community where
there was no compulsion
you know that you either choose to to
come into this community and be a part
of it or you don't
um but uh
you know that that had an appeal um
but yeah what drove you towards now
uh just one more before we go to the
next the crucifixion that jesus
peace be upon him who we love is one of
the mightiest messengers you know
muslims
he's a muslim unless he believes and
loves jesus right now that he died for
your sins
the crucifixion what were your thoughts
on that um
you know i i really didn't focus on you
know
as a kid you know what are my sins i was
late coming in from uh uh
late coming in for dinner uh you know it
was on
you know i wasn't out there you know in
terms of
of the commandments i wasn't killing
people i wasn't stealing from people you
know it's
so so the idea that that someone had
died for my sins it was
another story that people were telling
me and
you know it was i i endured the
compulsory
uh nature of going to church every
sunday and
you know i came home and picked up a
novel and went on with my life
so what point in the timeline now did
you decide to label yourself an agnostic
and define defined for our audience who
never heard this term what does it mean
to label your agnostic
well in my mind it kind of
means that understanding the
nature of the creator and of their
design for the creation is
above my pay grade it's not something
that i'm really
capable of saying definitively one way
or another and
you know i reach for that label because
when people
came to be aware that i had not
confirmed my faith in the presbyterian
church
had not you know held up my hand or
whatever
and swore to the trilogy into the um
what do they call it there was this uh
the creed
there's this uh
well there's a particular creed they
call it the bloody synod
and um in the early christian church
um they brought the bishops together and
apparently they were met with people
with swords who insisted that they
signed this document that was blank
we're going to figure out what we all
agree on but
you know you in order to not be killed
on your way through the door
you have to sign this document saying
that you've already agreed to what we're
about to talk about
and that was you know when you read the
history of
of um the nicean creed they call it
it was the council of nicaea that
formulated this and
uh they and in the history books they
call it the bloody synod
and you know that
basically to take the first communion
you're asked to
affirm your faith and you know jesus
as a a path to uh to
what we now i now understand is jenna
and to um and to say that you frame your
faith around this nicey and creed i
didn't know the history of the council
and i see it back then except
you know the story that had been told in
the communion class
or the catechism class
um but i knew that that
trinity thing you know i i couldn't wrap
my head around that at 12 or 13 or
years of age whatever however old i was
back then
so um in comparing notes with other
people
about the trinity like did you ask some
of your friends
did you were you seeing the same pattern
that people just you know
it wasn't my priority it was my parents
priority it wasn't my priority
yeah you got other things going on at
that age huh
yeah you know whatever it was i was
interested in at 13 years of age i don't
remember that was
40 years ago 45 years ago or something
um but you know people said well if
you're not a christian what are you
and so i i had to figure out you know an
answer to that
and so i had to do a little research and
and you know okay and i'm not jew and
i'm not hindu and i'm not
buddhist and i'm not you this and i'm
not that and um
you know i'm not an atheist i'm not
going to tell people that i don't
believe that there's a god because
you know that that question's above my
pay grant who knows
you know i'm 13 years old give me a
break let me
let me figure out other things maybe
i'll figure that out later or not
you know it wasn't a priority so i i
clicked on this word agnostic
which basically means that i don't know
i'm not going to tell you that i
know something that i don't know and it
seemed like the most honest way to
describe myself and
and that got me past this conversation
and this question
for you know what uh ten or a dozen
years
you know and then yeah and then we move
on to timeline
and then you become a buddhist
well that was later um i
i was a political organizer by the time
i was in my late twenties and
um and doing community organizing i
wound up being invited into uh
this community known as the rainbow
family of living light
and they hold these gatherings in the
forest
and um you know it's
some of it is new age huhu and some of
it is
is uh you know some sincere
efforts to to um connect
with uh with our
our kind of primal history of being
indigenous people
uh indigenous to this planet being in
relationship with the creation
um and it
you know there were all sorts of faith
traditions that
that were interwoven in the rainbow uh
community including
um including a lot of people who
identified as christian
of course but others who identified in
various uh
earth-based face generally known as
pagan
pagan faith about
that our relationship is not so much
with the creator but with the creation
itself
and as an environmental activist that
felt really comfortable to me
and so you know we would
gather in circles uh for the
new and the new moon and the
uh full moon and we would gather in
circles and
and share potluck meals around solstice
and
and the equinox and
um uh you know but
like all faith communities it it
provides a
um a sense of community a place to come
together a place to share
rituals a place to to connect with one
another
in the understanding that you know
there's something bigger than
our own personal experience that's going
on here in the world
but now that you look back were these
you mentioned the solstice you mentioned
some other things were these uh
when you unfolded them these are kind of
like pagan rituals
they are traditionally pagan rituals but
you know what i
noticed when i start started keeping the
five prayers
was that i had never been
more um in touch with
those changing seasons than i was when
i was keeping track of when the next
dawn was
gonna be sounded you know because
just like the the pagan community in
which islam was given
you know um the the islamic calendar is
a lunar calendar the and the rituals of
islam
are geared around the movement of the
the earth in relationship to the sun and
the changing of the seasons
and you know so i was able to and of
course
my first fast was right across the
summer solstice the longest day of the
year and i had known that as a pagan
that that was the longest day of the
year and so
i figured you know if i could if i could
make it through a fast that included the
solstice then you know
20 or 30 years in a from now uh
you know inshallah that i have the
opportunity to live that long that
uh you know when the fast
uh occurred during the winter it'd be
easier and you know it would never get
any more i would be lucky to live long
enough for the
for uh the fast to overlap with the
summer solstice and you know i don't
know how they do it up in lapland where
the days are 18 and 19 and 20
hours long you know but
um but you know that was my first
introduction to islam was
you know before i made shahada i made
the fast across the ramadan
how did you end up in hamas now so so we
the timeline okay
christian minister's son from there
you weren't really into that was the
teacher
right and then and then
you know i was comfortable calling
myself an agnostic pagan for a while
and and then even you were calling
yourself a a buddhist pagan
well later later um yes
before we get to islam so tell us share
with us
so i was with this um sister we were
together for 17 years
and um and she's buddhist and
and still practices and she's followed a
lot of different teachers over the
over the years but you know she's
um you know
one of the uh
you know one of the more spiritual
people that i've ever met
um and really beautiful woman in so many
ways
and she taught me so much and among the
things that she taught me was how to
meditate
and um or she took me to
her teacher who taught me how to
meditate she would
you know actively sought out teachers
who were willing to teach me how to
meditate
and you know i'd already been a
vegetarian for since 1986
so you know it wasn't a big step for me
to
you know learn how to sit quietly and
try to
clear the thoughts out of my skull and
focus on
you know so then i was calling myself an
agnostic pagan buddhist
you know i still had respect for now you
are calling yourself a what an agnostic
that's what you are calling yourself
when people would ask
you know i wasn't i wasn't out
proselytizing you know
my organizing was focused on political
issues and on community issues it wasn't
on matters of faith would people who've
practiced buddhism would they take
offense to that if you put that
in front of buddhism that term um
you know i suspect that there may be in
the world
people who count themselves as buddhists
who might take offense but
but the buddhists that i know didn't you
know
and and the boos that i knew didn't
really
weren't really asking me you know they
they practiced their faith they lived
their faith
you know and and some of them i mean i
i count among my friends uh buddhist
monks
and um and denise
and utsumi uh
have you know build a dojo here in
atlanta and
and i count them as dear friends and i
haven't seen them in a couple of years
but
um you know but
i i never felt i i never experienced
any buddhists proselytizing to me and
asking me about
my own practice they were they just
lived their practice you know so how do
you get to
islam now that you're actually in a
mosque a masjid
for if god so i'm
i take this new job up in alpharetta and
um there was a a
brother there named mirage who uh and
and
i i tell him uh you know mirage it's all
your fault and when i introduce
mirage to my friends and uh
in the local muslim community who you
may not previously know
i said you know it's his fault that you
gotta
that you're stuck with me now um but i
had just started this job and
you know a few weeks or a month or so
later
he comes and shares this flyer with me
and says we're doing an open house at
our mosque
and um and we'd love to have you come
and
you know we'll have a little food and
you know there'll be a little talk and
and uh you'll get to meet some of our
neighbors and
you know please come and you know this
was long before
i knew what dawah was or what it meant
or whatever but it was a dawah event
essentially
and um there's this uh
uh is it the frikan institute
i believe um and there's this brother
out in north carolina named imam isa who
drove down to be with us in in north
fulton
at the humza islamic center
and i drove out there and um
and mamisa had all these posters on the
wall and
basically it was debunking the myths of
of islam
you know as as we understand it and to
me
you know it started as a political
project
that um you know i'm a
political organizer i've been organizing
against
war since the 1970s or 80s
and well certainly since the
mid or late 80s i've been actively
organizing communities in opposition to
war
and i knew that for whatever
reason most of the people that seemed to
be under the bombs and the drones and
and
and the artillery shelling and the uh
small arms fire of uh paid for with my
nation's tax dollars seemed to be muslim
i didn't quite know why
you know i had not really well
i say i hadn't really dealt with muslims
before but
the reality is that once i entered the
muslim community i started realizing how
many muslims i had always dealt with
in my in my own circle of people
i just never connected them with with
islam
or or with the muslim community and you
know
and they had all these wonderful arabic
names and some of them wore kufi's and
you know uh and and all these different
signs that
were there to be seen i just wasn't
looking for them and so i didn't realize
that i had been known muslims all my
life
or all my adult life but you know at the
time
you know it was a political uh project
you know a piece of political
education i accepted his invitation to
go out there and
and and realize what i already knew is
that you know
it's the same heart underneath the skin
you know no matter
uh you know how you make prayer um
on whatever day you consider the sabbath
that we're all one
right and so i go to this
um i go out to this masjid in alpharetta
or uh the town just north alpharetta
whose name i'm skipping um i'm at hamza
and you know he's walking around the
walls of the masjid and at every place
where we stop he
explains some word or some concept or
you know and links to and debunk some
myths
and says you know you'll hear in the
media this but in reality it's more like
that and
you know and he in an hour or so he
he gave this presentation and
um and i went back and um
you know and and they handed me a quran
um on the way out the door and they
told me not to read it on the toilet and
i said but that's where i do all my
reading
you know so it's set up on a on a
a shelf uh you know unread
uh and um but
i decided as a result of of
or inspired by that that i would try the
fast
and um so one day i walked
over to mirage's desk tapped him on the
shoulder and i said
would you give me a heads up just let me
know when y'all start fasting
because we were you know just a few days
i was kind of keeping track
of of the calendar but we were a few
days out from ramadan but i knew that
you know it was all about
the local moon sighting although
apparently a lot of folks are following
uh saudi arabia on that but
um that you know some people thought the
fast would begin on this day
other people thought the fast would
begin on another day and so
uh i said just let me know when when you
all begin fasting if you would please
and so he did
and on that day i began fasting and we
were like
maybe a week into ramadan before he
realized that i was fasting too
and he's and you know he was all excited
mashallah and
whatever and um
and he said well if you're gonna fast
with us you have to come
enjoy the iftar celebration with us as
well
and i said what's an iftar celebration
and he said be here
come back to the masjid at this hour and
so he got me there
you know a few minutes before um before
my grib
and they started passing you know they
were handing me dates and and a bottle
of water as i walked through the door
they said okay i could i could go with
dates i enjoy dates and
and everyone um made salah
and um you know i sat in the back and
and meditated for 10 minutes like like
the buddhists taught me
and uh you know tried to stay out of
people's way
and and then they were everyone was
lining up for
uh this potluck in the back and
um you know it was really uncomfortable
um everyone kept trying to
tell me that i could sit down they would
bring me food
and they were they went to the front of
the line and they brought me food and
tried to hand it to me and i said you
know really i'm in this conversation
here with these folks in line
and i'm really enjoy getting to know
people you don't have to feed me it's
all good i'm willing to be patient i've
waited all day to eat i could wait a
few more minutes till i get to the front
of the line of my own accord
and so i continued the conversation with
the brothers there
and we got to the front of the line and
you know i was grateful that they had
vegetarian
options and uh the food was exquisite it
was
you know it's mostly a south asian
community at hamza and
and i've always been fond of indian and
pakistani food and
you know so that was really comfortable
for me and
and then uh afterwards uh
uh people lined up for uh isha
and i went back and sat in the back and
meditated like the buddhists had taught
me
and um uh
they uh uh and and then they
lined up for uh um
uh uh i'm flaking on the name of it the
prayer you stand for prayer after the
uh yes
yeah and and right and
you know i would slip out after a few
were caught and
i didn't know to call them rakat at the
time but i'd go home and
get a little sleep and get ready for
work the next day
um you know and so one day i'm
standing in line there during the iftar
and
um they asked uh
you know and and he looked at me kind of
incredulously you mean you're not
you're not muslim i said no sir well
what are you
well you know i had i had the rap down
you know i'm
probably more like a i don't know maybe
an agnostic paga buddhist
and he said mashallah you're in the
perfect place
and so you know i made uh it not every
night
but uh i was i started making the iftars
out at with
the brothers out of the atoms uh you
know several nights a week
and um and every night i would sit in
the back
during um during the salah and
uh meditate like they taught me uh
to do as a buddhist and um then it came
to be eid
and um and i kept trying to be in the
back but
you know the the they rented this giant
banquet hall
and they kept filling up and getting
tighter and tighter and there was no
place for me to spread out my knees and
meditate like they taught me to do as a
buddhist and so
for the first time i found myself making
salah as if i were a muslim
i hadn't made shahada or nothing i just
you know and
but you know i took on the practices one
by one
okay well i'll go to a doll with okay
i'll try it fast okay
well look at that i made uh for rakai
even though i didn't have a clue with
what i was doing there and um you know
it'd be another
it was in the coming year that you know
i finally
um mirage was on vacation at the time
but there was another muslim brother
there uh in
our office and and we had we would get
one of the conference rooms
uh for dora and oscar
mirage comes back from india where he's
been visiting family
and um and he comes in
and uh in the meantime
i had learned to make a comma
uh the other brother had insisted you
you already learned how to make
the uh well this was af after that first
fast yeah but you still you learned
how to make this the call to prayer
before you actually accepted islam
took the shadow indeed yes and
and so i was making a comma and um
and you know uh
uh owen turned around and and told me to
make a comma
and and mirage
you know gave me this quizzical look and
so i started
making it and as soon as i uh
got through um uh rasulullah he
he interrupted and said mashallah
you know you just made shahadah and and
he had always promised that
you know if uh that once he made shahada
that you know
his wife would be happy to help uh
arrange for
uh a bride for me to marry
and i i you say what was slow down slow
down you know and
uh but he um uh
um i said
can we get back to it and you know
because i gotta you know
finish this prayer and get back to work
and i got some deadline or another
whatever at work and
and so we went through the prayer but
barrage was so ecstatic
it was kind of funny but yeah that
that's uh that was
that was my first year yeah wow
so any regret regrets
uh we're still making war all over the
planet i can't figure out why
women are still not safe in their homes
i wish it were different yeah yeah i got
regrets but you know
not about my spiritual path
we're almost out of time now let's get
your um advice for those people who are
out there
and they have like so many are
hypnotized by the media and this helps
to just
nurture and foster this hate towards
islam
now you're a muslim i mean what kind of
impression what were your thoughts about
islam before you accepted it
and now for those people who have these
kind of negative stereotypes
you being a muslim now an american come
from a christian background
what would you say to those type of
people out there
well um in terms of what i understood
about muslims before was that they were
demonized by a media that i didn't trust
you know this is the same media that
seemed to want to justify killing people
and yeah and
it never added up was didn't sound like
a very christian thing to do although
i was told we were a christian nation
and we had to do this in the name of
christianity some people would even go
so far as to say
we have to go kill these people in the
name of christianity you know
samuel clemens mark twain whatever you
call him he had this
uh poem he wrote or not a short story
called the war prayer
where um and i don't remember the
details of it but
it was basically this pastor
sends the pulpit and offers a prayer
for our side's victory in a war
this i think may have been inspired by
the us
war to occupy mexico and to extend the
institution of slavery
into texas and and south of the rio
grande or maybe it was the civil war i
don't remember exactly when he wrote
this
piece but um uh
you know and and it always struck me the
the hypocrisy you know right there in
the
in the commandments that uh uh musa
may peace be upon him uh is told we are
told
what brought down on the tablets you
know that thou shalt not kill
except when we say that it's you know
the christian thing to do apparently but
um you know it tore my stomach up when
um daddy bush started his war against
iraq
and it did it again when his when his
son did it again
and you know in the meantime uh
in the interim we had uh uh what's the
dude's name clinton from arkansas
was making war against the people in in
serbia and croatia and i had no idea
what that was about
you know but um none of it seemed right
and and then um you know
i watch a couple of planes fly into
buildings and
and office buildings one day and
um and suddenly we're supposed to
uh hate uh afghanis
and go to war against their people and
destroy their land and
um and i was kept trying to figure out
but what does that have to do with this
foolishness you know it's
it's clear that this was an inside job
you don't get
three planes flying into office
buildings without some sort of inside
collusion let's be real about this
what's this got to do with afghanistan
but it was
seen you know perfectly reasonable and
everyone around me thought it was
perfectly reasonable to go
kill children in afghanistan for some
reason
uh you know and and you know
of course the federally uh the federal
territories on the northern border you
know who knows where the border between
afghanistan and pakistan is you know
well they're all brown folks anyway it's
okay to kill them
and none of this added up and you know i
was
organizing uh anyone i could find
who was opposed to it to take action
against it in any way that we
could figure out how to take action and
to be visible in our opposition to the
war and
and um you know so
the media told me it was okay for us to
go kill people
and now the media was telling us it was
okay to you know
to be fearful of or or hateful towards
or
wage war against the muslim world
that didn't make any more sense to me
than you know any of the rest of it
and um but you know
uh
the the community is is
just as loving in um
in our massages as it is in any
uh church christian church community
i've ever been
and the food is generally better and
healthier
and at least you know at least out this
way
uh among the asian community and
um and uh you know they
tend to have a uh
a more learned perspective on the world
and be less insular um
you know i get exposed to more cultures
and more perspectives and more
um uh and
uh more perspectives on
on how the world operates and because
at least you know and and it doesn't
matter i've
i've attended uh uh the prayers in
uh in las jids in
three different states now or massages
in three different states and and
wherever i go
you know i i line up in the ranks and
i'm in instantly welcomed
and you know there's this there's this
sense of community and brotherhood
there and you know i'm told that and of
course
that's probably available in most any
faith
that is you know really about building
community and building support for one
another
but i also find that
the muslim community seems to be a lot
less insular
you know the free medical clinics that
we put up are not just for
the members of the congregation you know
it's
when we feed the hungry it's like
everyone who's hungry not just the
people
who come and pray with us uh
you know when we respond to the storms
and the disasters that you know
no one's asking you you whether you made
shahada or
you know if you're keeping the prayers
or or you know
are you one of those dreaded uh agnostic
pagan uh uh buddhist you know
it's mashallah you're in the perfect
place how
how wonderful it is to have you here
you know it's a lived faith you know
it's uh it's a lift faith that is
exhibited in
in how people treat one another you know
they say a muslim is someone who
is safe from the words of the from the
hands and the tongue
of this fellow muslim
we want to thank you esko for sharing
your story with us
god willing inshallah we can inspire so
many more people
out there who have so many
misconceptions about islam
they can be motivated to read the quran
to go visit
a mosque for maybe iftar like you did
yeah so thank you very much thank you
i'm looking forward to the next
opportunity to be with you
and shalom me too thank you very much
and thank you guys for tuning in like i
said we're not just telling a story
we're inspiring people
helping to change lives for the better
and hopefully this story can resonate
with you so it will motivate you
to go ahead and look in to the most
misunderstood way of life yes
it's the fastest growing way of life in
the world islam submission to the
creator
not the creation the same god that jesus
moses abraham and the last and final
messenger said the man kind of prophet
muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him worship living
the true purpose of life and why you've
been created thank you very much we'll
see you next time peace be with you
assalamu